when you talk about Michael Phelps you
have to talk about the genesis of the
multi metal winner in the pool and it
all began with the man that we're about
to talk to you right now Mark Spitz had
the poster that every kid had in their
room in the 70s with those seven medals
across his chest so up well well lined
up and the moustache and his arms folded
and he also people don't realize that he
started really started the swimming
revolution in the United States that's
when you saw every neighborhood have a
swim team when kids were getting in the
pool and it was like yeah yeah I'm
swimming everything because Mark Spitz
he was the Olympic hero for us of the
Munich games he joins us now in mark
thanks for joining us and how are you
doing I'm doing great thanks for on me
on I gotta ask you what's it like
watching Michael Phelps right now after
you really were the guy who set the
standard what are you like is there a
camaraderie do you feel what Phelps is
going through as you watch him I don't
know if there's a camaraderie between
the two plus I've hardly spoken to him
just briefly sometimes giving him an
award that he made with the team and
stuff like that I've given him awards
for swimming and different functions and
he's basically gone up and thanked
everybody to the award so it's been a
small conversation be honest with you he
um so rejuvenated not my career because
i'm not in swimming anymore but you know
having a record there was 36 years old
all of a sudden that record was mine and
then I became focus of how great he
really was that's what about the light
what I had done you know watching him
swim he schooling everybody to be honest
with you he's just incredible he lost
his focus as far as I can see from the
Olympic Games that was in Beijing in
2008 and I was hard from them after
winning eight gold medals and breaking
my record that he focused and he I don't
think he trained hard on that for
whatever it might have been in the
olympic games in london for years later
and he had some losses and i think it
really got to him and he said he was
retiring but I said all along
that's not last long and it didn't I
think it lasts like 14 months he's back
in the pool training and he had some
things that were happening to him in his
life socially and and you know he gets
scolded for having some kind of an
alcohol issue with a speeding ticket and
he got his act together last year and
he's got a fiance and he's got a new son
and he's got a different set of
objectives and he is now as I'm speaking
with you as 14 gold medals and I mean
you get to events left one tonight and
the hundred meter butterfly its its
toughest of that I mean he usually wins
that event but he wins by hundreds of a
second and you know keeping that in mind
he's 31 years old but there's a teammate
he's got anthony ervin there wasn't a
thousand olympic games in the 50
freestyle and he won that and he's
qualified in the finals the seeming to
swim that again and I mean so it's not
out of the realm that Michael could
stick around and be 35 in Tokyo and four
years from now I you know since he knows
only his whole life swimming and the
thrill of winning and the fact that he
loves competing and racing I went on
record about two days ago and said you
know he's swimming so well it is mine if
you stead of some six events in Tokyo in
stones one or two he'll figure he
doesn't have to work as hard and you
might stick around so guess what we'll
have to wait and see for ourselves but I
think it's a strong busted on it let's
put it that way I hear ya um let me ask
you this how hard is it to walk away
from something you've done your entire
life you had a career goal in options
outside of swimming but still it had to
be tough and how hard do you think it
will be for Michael when he finally does
hang it up well is it to differences uh
one major and that is that at the time I
slam you couldn't be a professional so
for me to make a few dollars which I did
I had to give up the sport and it was
something sort of done you know prior to
my going to deal of the games that most
people who had been in olympic games and
then approached a year at the age of 22
23 whatever after my college scholarship
it exhausted which it was ironically on
that same year in 72 I needed to go on
to dental school and I had other focus
today if the rules of
the same bag and then you know I would
have been able to make I would have been
able to make the same money that I made
by turning professional but my sponsors
would have encouraged me to stay in the
sport and I probably would have as well
so i probably would have gone to the
montréal games four years later I mean
look at I wasn't chasing much spits his
record or I wasn't chasing now for
example somebody is chasing Michael
Phelps record so you know I had been the
true Olympic Games I had two gold silver
bronze in 68 go to MEK go to Munich and
win seven gold medals and world records
that I had anticipated a year before
that every single race that I was going
to do is gonna be my last and I sort of
relished the fact that that was the end
of my career looking if you asked me if
Michael wins tonight and when's the
relay tomorrow I mean six gold medals
that's a great way to finish he's got
what we have like 20 he's got 22 build
medals right now if he wins 24 if he
wins two more gold medals I was just
pointed this out the other day that he
will have tied the amount of gold medals
that the host city Brazil has one in the
all-time ever since the Olympics has
ever been invented so he's won as much
as the country has over 100 and some odd
years so that's quite an accomplishment
hey Mark where do you keep your gold
medals when you have so many and do you
ever loan one out do you ever let
anybody touch him you know they've been
in a bank vault since the moment I
touched ground coming back from Munich
only some reason that I didn't want
somebody to think that they come and
visit them next in my home and they've
been there ever since so do you ever go
visit them do you ever go see him I
think we might have lost mark walk off
maybe I don't know we might have lost
them I think yeah we're having trouble
Fritzi work work on that we got to get
Mark Spitz back but that's amazing that
he is not seeing his medals since Munich
because when you think back to the
Munich games remember that's when the US
basketball team lost they lost to Russia
and when they lost to Russia they
refused to accept their silver medals
medals so those silver medals are still
in a bank vault in Germany so those guys
have never picked him up Doug Collins
never went and got his silver medal and
so it's interesting that's defiance yes
that's the fun but Mark Spitz won his
and like you know he did the pose
he did all that stuff in his or sitting
in a bank vault that's pretty amazing to
think about it's just you know those
metals I'm sure so many people come to
his house or they just hang out or he
shows up someplace and they're like dude
where's the metals bring the metals and
also people need to remember during
those games that while Mark Spitz was
being celebrated and there are things
going on athletically we will never get
over what happened with the the athletes
from Israel but let me get more we got
mark back hey Mark let me just recap
real quick do you ever visit the metals
just go see them I've only seen him
actually three times wants to take him
out for a picture that i was paid for by
a French magazine that was about five or
six years after I had finished swimming
and then on the anniversary of each of
my two sons birthdays at seven years old
I took them out and placed them on their
shoulders and hung them around their
their necks actually the same way I took
my picture you know years before so it's
sort of a personal thing that's kind of
cute they're so small I think that that
age of seven that metals are practically
on the glass but they have that iconic
picture because I mean I don't know a
kid in America who didn't have that
picture or know somebody with that
poster and um let me ask you this do you
ever think about growing the mustache
back well not at all no you know I had I
grew it out of spite because my coach in
college said you gotta look like the
all-american and not to have it and then
I grew it took so long to come in that I
went to deliver trials in Chicago in
1972 for swimming for the Olympics and
there was everybody was talking about my
mustache I figured well maybe I
shouldn't sit off they're worried about
my mustache and not figuring out how to
beat me so it worked in the Olympic
Trials and I kept it through the
Olympics and it sort of it was sort of
that weird because everybody was shaving
their heads and wearing yeah that's and
you know bathing caps and whatever to go
fast and I just said hey look what this
was working and I didn't want to change
wow that is amazing I don't ask you is
they're gay men ship or was there
gamesmanship our trash talk
then because we saw what happened with
Phelps and Chadwick low and does that
kind of stuff go on in swimming well
back in my day not really um look at
people in a different time you know we
got Twitter Facebook everything else are
pending I mean people have an opinion
and they're going to give you your
opinion what do you want to hear it or
not i think that there's a little
jealousy involved and look at Chad you
know stuck it to him in the Olympics and
that's what all competitions about and
be honest with you there's always a chat
in somebody's life there's a chat in my
life the guide named Doug Russell that
beat me in the 100-meter butterfly and
Mexico City and took the gold medal away
from me I got a second and I was the
world record holder and I didn't get to
someone the relay so this guy had the
race of his life wins gold medal on the
individual event went to gold medal in
the relay and you know so that was the
reason I stuck with the sport for
another four years and maybe that's the
reason to Phelps is so strong today you
know what happened doing for years ago
in London yeah it's it's a great point
market thanks so much for taking the
time out to join us and um look I got to
tell you what an honor it is to talk to
you you're a guy who I watched every one
of those races when you were in Munich
and I had the poster and so it's great
to talk to you and I'm just and bring
those medals out man every one more time
just bring them out take a new picture
all right yeah look I don't have to do
that I'll let Michael Phelps do that and
you know something with all due respect
you got to watch this guy because it's
what happened in our life and it may
never happen again records are made to
be broken but this one is quite
incredible thanks so much mark mark
spitz one of the greatest of all time
and a man who changed swimming in
America remember always look back to the
moment that changed like the culture
Mark Spitz change the culture of this
country and made us all appreciate
swimming the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience